ich wurde eingeladen und nicht von
irgendwem zu irgendwas sondern von
Michelin zu einem exklusiven VIP Dinner
und als ich das gesehen habe muss ich
ganz ehrlich sagen ich glaube das war
die coolste Anfrage die ich persönlich
für mich selbst jemals bekommen habe ihr
wisst selbst ich bin fasziniert von
Essen von einfachem essen aber auch von
gehobener Sternegastronomie und
Micheline für diejenigen von euch die es
vielleicht nicht wissen zeichnet
Restaurants mit Sternen aus also wenn
man von sterneestaurants und von
Sterneköchen redet steht im Hintergrund
Michelin die diese Köche und diese
Restaurants ausgezeichnet hat die
höchste Auszeichnung die ein Koch auf
dieser Erde bekommen kann sind drei
michelon Sterne und ihr merkt gerade
dass ich immer ein bisschen Wechsel
zwischen Michelin und michelon es gibt
ja auch einen Reifenhersteller der
Michelin heißt und dann gibt es den geid
Michler also den restaurant guide und
das Besondere ist dass beides die
gleiche Firma ist das hat nämlich auch
ein ganz einfachen Hintergrund und zwar
hat damals der Autohersteller Micheline
sich gedacht wie können wir mehr
Autoreifen verkaufen indem die Leute meh
mehr Auto fahren ursprünglich bedeutet
ein Stern nämlich dass das Restaurant
ein Stopp wert ist zwei Sterne bedeuten
dass das Restaurant ein Umweg wert ist
und drei Sterne bedeuten dass das
Restaurant eine eigene Reise wert ist
wieder was gelernt bei dem heutigen
Dinner bin ich nicht in irgendeinem
Restaurant sondern ich bin wieder im
teuersten Restaurant meiner Stadt hier
in Köln im ochx und Klee das Restaurant
in dem Eric und ich 15 Gänge für über
700 € gegessen haben und das beste ist
ich war nicht nur wie die anderen Gäste
zum Dinner eingeladen sondern ich konnte
Daniel gotschlich zum Menü befragen und
habe sogar mit ihm gemeinsam ein Gang
angerichtet erste Frage ist es für dich
genauso besonders von Michelin für so
ein Abend angefragt zu werden wie für
mich es ist jetzt keine gewöhnliche
Anfrage so von wegen so ja irgendjemand
möchte vielleicht eine Feier ausrichten
sondern das ist schon eher so ein
wirklich besonderes Event was war die
Aufgabenstellung mit der Micheline an
Dich herangetreten ist was was solltest
du machen was sollte das Menü
transportieren und wie hast du das ganze
angegangen Michelinreifen haben halt
bestimmte Eigenschaften und das um das
jetzt sage ich mal darzustellen ja
gibt's natürlich dann bestimmte Ansätze
ja die Michelin natürlich dann
vorgegeben hat und auf diese Ansätze hin
habe ich dann das Menü gestaltet ja um
das dann auch sag ich mal kulinarisch zu
transportieren was dann eigentlich das
Besondere an den Reifen ist und ich
glaube das ist schon eine Besonderheit
und das das kann auch nicht jeder dass
man einfach etwas wie einen Autoreifen
kulinarisch transportiert ich habe schon
gehört wie es da auch teilweise zugeht
wir Arbeit oder du arbeitest mit mit
einer Asche du hast dann quasi das das
Profil weil die Besonderheit ist ja
heute abend 1,6 mm Dinner dass man die
michelinenreifen eher eben länger fahren
kann als die von der Konkurrenz also
irgendwie sonst 2 bis 3 mm
Mindestprofiltiefe be Micheline 1,6 und
diese 1,6 wie habt ihr die in den
Vordergrund gestellt wie habt ihr damit
gearbeitet im kreativen Prozess wo wir
überlegt haben okay was machen wir den
jetzt eigentlich haben wir halt die Idee
gehabt tatsächlich so eine Art Profil
was es auch tatsächlich gibt von
Michelin haben wir dann übersetzt und
haben dieses Profil in so eine
Silikonform gebracht WoW und diese
Silikonform ist tatsächlich auch genau
1,6 mm hoch und das heißt nachher auf
dem Teller findet man halt diesen dieses
Profil wieder und ich ich finde das so
das macht auch Sterneküche aus für mich
dass man so wenn man an Kochen denkt
dann denkt man nicht an eine Form 3D
drucken Asche herstellen aus R
waberschal und das besondes ich glaube
so viel kann ich jetzt schon sagen es
wird halt unglaublich gut schmecken auch
noch ne das ist das ist einfach das
kommt immer noch dazu ne also das coole
Aussehen ist eine Sache ne aber es muss
halt auch schmeckenr gibt es von den von
den Gängen ein auf den du besonders
stolz bist wo du sagst das ist der
krasseste heute Abend ist natürlich den
den wir zusammen kochen habe ich dann
wenn ich das gekocht habe habe ich dann
zwei Sterne nicht direkt aber du hast
auf jeden Fall schon mal mit dem zwei
stne Koch gekocht hast du das schon mal
gemacht nö noch nie hast du schon mit
einem Youtuber gekocht nee siehst du
guck dann sollen wir noch genau das
jetzt machen gehen wir mal in die Küche
und dann zaubern wir ein zwei Sterne
Gericht let's go machen wir wenn ich da
heute drüber nachdenke war das wirklich
special also mit einem zwei stne Koch da
zu sitzen der uns wirklich in die
Entstehung von dem Menü mitnimmt das
habt ihr euch ja auch gewünscht dass ich
noch mal ein bisschen tiefergehend auf
dieses entstehungsthema eingehe das ist
einfach krass also bin sehr happy solche
Sachen erleben zu dürfen und ich bin
auch froh euch dabei mitnehmen zu können
die Küche gleicht eigentlich schon fast
mehr einem Labor als einer normalen
Küche weil alles ist perfekt sauber an
Ort und Stelle und jeder steht einfach
stramm um die bestmöglich Arbeit zu
verrichten in dem Umfeld durfte ich mich
jetzt austoben und wir haben einfach mal
losgelegt ich wurde komplett ins kalte
Wasser geworfen plötzlich stehe ich da
iner zwei Sterneküche und ich soll
selbst etwas machen und Daniel hat mich
aber gut angeleitet hat mir gesagt wir
machen zuerst einmal eine Masse für
diese kleinen Chips die wir später
brauchen werden wir haben einmal
zerlassene Butter Salz wir haben eine XO
passe wir haben Ei weiß Mehl Puderzucker
Lebensmittelfarbe alles wurde perfekt
abgemessen zusammengemischt bis wir
diese rote Masse hatten mus mus trotz
Rezept trotzdem noch abschmecken ist
sehr positiv verlaufen würde ich sagens
abschmecken schon sehr intensiv die
haben wir dann gebacken und uns in der
Zwischenzeit um die Garnelen gekümmert
die Chips sind eigentlich Tropfen wie
man sie im Querschnitt von dem
Michelinreifen sieht also auch hier
wieder mit Köpfchen dabei aber für mich
war erstmal oberste Priorität nicht zu
verkacken den krilengriff das kann kann
kann richtig aus den Garnelen haben wir
ein Tat hergestellt das abgeschmeckt
wurde und es war verdammt
lecker
wow kommt diese Nussigkeit V von dem
Distelöl ja probier mal
einzeln das ist mega nussig ist ja krass
das mach richtig Spaß geil Hammer und
ich habe jetzt gerade mehr oder weniger
habe ich zumindest die handschritte mit
verfolgt das ist ja total easy geil dann
haben wir auch schon einen setzring
genommen auf diesen crazy Teller
gestellt mit garnelentatar gefüllt
schaut euch bitte einfach alleine mal
diesen Teller
an perfekt läuft doch Perf das ist fast
Kunst also so eine
glasblase auf der man dann sein Essen
anrichtet auch sowas findet man
eigentlich nur in Sternerestaurants und
all das für eine Handvoll Menschen und
nur für einen Abend das ist wirklich das
Verrückteste was ich auch noch immer
nicht ganz realisiert habe dieses Menü
gab es nur an einem Abend und nur für
eine Gruppe Menschen und ich gehöre dazu
das ist wirklich besonders und das kann
mir auch keiner nehmen also ging es ans
anrichten setzring garnelentatar
soßentropfen drauf gesetzt die roten
Tropfen platzi
ein bisschen Kresse dazu und mit
marakuya Kern finalisiert unglaublich
und am meisten habe ich mich natürlich
wie immer aufs Essen gefreut wie wie
essen wir das jetzt am besten einfach
mal Löffel rein hier und auf geht's und
das ja das schlaue man hat wirklich
direkt alles auf einem Löffel
[Musik]
drauf boah das ist so intensiv ganz geil
geworden aber wie das scheucht ein
wieder so nach links und rechts man weiß
gar nicht was man schmeckt so so
vielseitig ist das freue mich dass ich
heute Abend noch mal essen darf also
wirklich und da muss ich nicht mal
selbst machen bist der einzige von dem
also ich bin der Einzige der zweimal ist
so wir sind jetzt angekommen beim Dinner
wir wurden erstmal empfangen hier es
gibt verschiedene kleine Happen dazu
kölch es war wirklich ein krasser
Empfang also direkt mit Drinks versorgt
man hat sich umgeschaut und keine Ahnung
da waren Paul Ripke kamuschka und Niklas
aber auch Carsten hen der
Restaurantkritiker der schon auf meinem
Kanal zu Gast war man war auf jeden Fall
in guter Gesellschaft nicht zuletzt weil
auch Dave da war dann wurde auch schon
die Moderation eingeleitet von einer TV
Moderatorin das ist kreative
Höchstleistung das habe ich vermiss ich
an vielen Stellen in meinem Leben sonst
was jer gemacht hat lasst euch
überraschen es wird wirklich also
kulinarisch Klasse sag ich mal für alles
andere leiichen Wohls wird natürlich
gesorgt und danach wurde auch schon der
erste Gang fliegend serviert also
einfach dort wo wir waren im Stehen im
ersten Gang den wir jetzten haben wir
gleich zwei Bestandteile die auch in den
Reifen vorhanden sind glaubt man
vielleicht nicht orangenstale und
sonnenblumenö ist beidesinreifen drin
hoffentlich schme das nicht wie ein
Reifen ich bin fast sicher dass gut
schmecken
[Musik]
wird crunchy bisschen Säure super lecker
also ich glaub heute wird richtig SP
find das wirklich unglaublich dass schon
in diesem ersten Gang echte Bestandteile
vom Reifen also die wirklich in den
Reifen drin sind in ein so leckeres und
vor allem so schön anzuschauendes
Gericht übersetzt wurden Reifen
Sterneküche das ist wirklich verrückt
aber das hat funktioniert und es war
richtig lecker und hat richtig Lust auf
weitere Gänge gemacht den zweiten Gang
kennt ihr schon das ist der den ich am
Vormittag mit Daniel gemacht habe und
ich habe eine klare Meinung
dazu auch noch heute und dann haben wir
Gang für Gang bekommen und es wurde
immer besser eine Dampfnudel mit Cavia
und
[Musik]
Banane crazy Banane und Cavia ne der
Klassiker aber schmeckt so gut Zander
mit Vanille und einem Reifenprofil aus
rababerasche g
sch Kalbsfilet mit Apfel und der größten
Portion Trüffel die ich jemals gesehen
habe ich konnte nicht mehr dazu sagen
weil ein lecker bis dahin war das eine
unvergessliche Erfahrung dieses Menü
konn nur wir dort nur für einen Abend
essen und ich habe jeden Moment davon
genossen es war unglaublich lecker
wunderschön anzuschauen und einfach ein
unvergesslicher Abend an der Stelle
deshalb noch mal dankeeschön an
Micheline für die Einladung aber jeder
noch so schöner Abend muss ein Ende
finden deshalb haben wir das Restaurant
verlassen uns wieder nach unten begeben
und zum Dessert gab es dann Sonnenblume
mit Orangenblüte und Topinambur die habe
ich nicht alleine gegessen sondern mit
Peter von peizsmet und den letzten
Moment des Abends noch mal in vollen
Zügen genossen ich habe ein ger an
meiner Seite den Höch persönlich
[Musik]
einfachin ballert aber wie super
vielseitig florale zwisin du hast das
sonnenblum auf jeden Fall sehr krass
aber gleichzeitig auch so Zitrusnoten
die halt voll rausreißen weil sonst wär
es zu schwer
fettig crun von diesemen chipuf also
auch hier wieder Leute es ist einfach
Feierabend heute Warin
auch von der Erfahrung her eine absolute
V wir sehen uns im Büro Freunde ich
hoffe ihr konntet ansatzweise verstehen
was das für ein unglaublicher Abend auch
für mich war weil das ist eine Sache die
ich wahrscheinlich nie wieder in meinem
Leben haben werde es ist unglaublich
wenn sogar Carsten hen der
Restaurantkritiker sagt das erlebe ich
auch nicht wie heute das glaube ich
gerne der ist hauptberuflich in feinen
Restaurants und nicht mal er hat das
erlebt unglaublich danke fürs zuschauen
lass gerne und komm da wir sehen uns
beim nächsten Mal wieder ciao ciao